let's begin first one now you may think
whoa this is a long time ago okay so
this is all the way back in a and one
but that's one of the reasons why we
review it because when you get to a test
it's all that stuff which was done a
long time ago that's easy to forget so
where did I get look that's not what I
want to do where did I get this pair of
turns on where are they filmed yeah good
so I've expanded this guy here and I
said well the 4 goes to the X then the 4
goes to the +1 that's where those two
things come from you tell me what do you
think would be the most common error
when you do the expansion over here what
do you guys reckon yeah it's going to be
that double negative right and it's easy
to just say oh minus this minus that but
of course you've got to have both of
these guys interacting together and when
you multiply to NATO's gives you a
positive okay what I do from the second
line to the third layer what happened
next like yeah I collected like terms
right we have this catch-all word of
simplifying which is what's happened all
the way down but you guys know we have
specific language for this and more
specific you can be better so X minus
two thumbs up yep let's have a look at
this guy now I solve the equation what
was the best way to go about this we try
to find out what you was okay so you can
see you can see the approach i took now
i will point out as we've seen in
equations right there's lots of
different ways to go about this if you
if you landed here i'm pretty confident
that if you're landing in that's okay
but maybe you took a harder path so let
me explain what did i do from line 12
line two I'm multiplied through now the
reason why is because I just didn't want
to deal with the fraction it just looked
gross to me okay so if i multiply this
and this and this everything by 3 then
the factory disappears
okay okay now Shh remember you're 11
let's try and get through this hour do
once you discuss it just at the right
time okay so leave that to the end you
might look at that number at the it's a
bit weird like 15 / 17 really but
there's no reason to doubt like 15 years
I've ever 17 is a weird number by could
actually do something with this what
could I do to check to make sure I was
actually right yeah you've got the first
line in here which apparently should
work if I got the right value of you now
you could do that by hand but of course
you've got a calculator which you can do
this for you right so I guess what I put
into this guy is a six times this 15 /
17 business- just be careful with your
fraction tier 15 / 17 on three right and
what do you expect to your calculator
and hand you you're hoping it's giving
you five and you can go ahead and
confirm that but I'm pretty confident in
the way we've gone back to working
question you mean you mean you got this
answer but you checked out and something
went wrong so you do have to be careful
i pointed out you know you use are you
use a calculator to do something like
this but i'd expect perhaps somewhere
and maybe that right hand part the
fraction on the fraction you can
sometimes enter that wrong should be
careful i'm happy to have a look at what
you actually pushed it let's move on
what do you think are you happy with a
six point seven three times said to this
yeah we're getting pretty good at this
so you can see I've done it in two steps
because there's a good chance a question
like this should be two marks and if you
went straight here and you got it right
Thank good for you but what if you made
like you round it wrong but you had the
right tinto that whatever if you shown
the working like I have up here then at
least you can work out okay I've got one
of those two marks and if you look at
that thing that something's gone wrong
at least you can go back to your working
okay all right now lastly I had a look
around and I think some of us responded
to this by saying dunno flip the table
and walk off okay so let's just just
think for a second admittedly this
maybe phrase in a way you haven't seen
before so let's just think it through
right the mass of a can of soup it gets
measured right now I should say that
this bit on the end is actually kind of
they're trying to give you a hand whoops
that's not what I want to do because you
could actually have known that last bit
but nearest ten grams business you could
have done that without me telling you
how could you have known have a look
it's 240 grams right so again we think
about significant figures right they
don't have to tell you oh this is to two
significant figures if you got a zero
there well that could just as easily
have been as the result of rounding
right so that kind of implies okay this
is supposed to be the nearest 10 grams
but they gave you a bit of a notch I
gave you a bit of a nudge so then when
you think about error right this whole
idea is if you think about it's easiest
to think about a ruler I find and we use
this with our original thing suppose it
was let's talk about centimeters wasn't
like that so suppose he is 2 30 to 40 to
50 right so you remember this idea of
saying okay if it's somewhere in between
240 and 250 but it's closer to 240 then
that's why I'm going to round down to
that and the same on the opposite side
so this idea of absolute error if your
call it is half of what was that phrase
cord start with an L remember yeah this
this difference here which in this case
was well 10 centimeters are 10 grams
whatever that's the limit of reading so
you can see going either side is going
to be 5 grams this way five grams to
that way okay so that's why the absolute
error let's just get rid of all this the
absolute error is five grams okay so you
get the percentage error off that
obviously so this is a bit tricky if you
could do the first part you couldn't
access the second part which is room hey
um if for example you actually answered
something like say suppose you said 10
grams okay add that one which is which
is wrong but if you went ahead and use
that here there's a good chance your
dinner because what we're testing is do
you know how these two relate
and then can you convert to a percentage
and if you did that with the wrong
number then yeah which part did you
cross out okay sure so what if you set a
jar I'm comparing the error with what I
actually measured yeah so that's why I
get this fraction here your calculator
will tell you 0.02 etc and then I've
just multiplied by 100 that okay don't
ask ok sure it just stretching all right
let's move over to this uh this guy over
here you've got the ad equilateral
triangle and I was really pleased you
didn't have to do this but I was really
pleased to see a lot of you just just
drew something like it's cool to draw
something because that will help you get
a picture like literally a picture of
what's going on if all of the sides are
equal then 3 by 7 21 so that's all I was
looking for now I had a look around as
you were going through for what answers
you provide it for Part B so a lot of
you went straight there and I'm okay
with that and okay with that however let
me give a bit of a caveat here um that's
okay in this case because where does
that 1.5 come from by the way like it
doesn't come from nowhere it comes from
the fact that I've measured three times
right side side side and every time I
could be off by half a cinnamon so it's
three lots of half a centimeter that's
what gives you that normal ok I'm going
to encourage you if you wrote down only
one a half centuries where you get your
paperback from your friend can you put
something down like this I know this
seems like why it's a bit excessive
isn't it like it's a lot simpler and
faster just to work out three times one
half but that approach doesn't really
work if you're doing area does it right
you remember we were doing area and it's
a lot more complicated that you've got
to know the maximum then the middle and
then you make a comparison based on that
okay so this is kind of a arm this
approach will always work where is this
approach it work because what I gave you
a simpler question in this case but if
it's harder you're going to need to
remember on this is actually how I'm
doing it okay this is how comparing the
errors on either side versus what I
think the area eliminar
actually it is does that make sense so
I'm going to courage you to do that and
I'll put that back on the screen you
didn't